[Music]
I'm Karen Karen King and I run the New
Kent Art Gallery in broadstairs this is
our sixth year now nearly our seventh
and it's evolved over the last six years
and now it's a sort of collective of
nine artists and the guest artists each
month
um that show their work here
so I started out as an illustrator I did
books children's books and sort of
encyclopedias and coffee table sort of
guides to Nature and that was my
specialism originally and moved to here
about six years ago and started to do
more Fine Art and paintings and yes I'll
just see what happens with the gallery
space and it's just been fantastic and
the response has been wonderful from
from visitors and residents alike every
summer is a is a absolutely mad time for
us but even even off season now the
winter months and we get a lot of day
Trippers and visitors which is nice to
see which is has definitely evolved
since six years ago it's become more and
more and more so
what people like about our Gallery in
particular is that it is all locally
made and they often will get to meet the
artist or the maker and that's quite a
nice personal connection and people I
think if people want to buy a piece of
art they really want that person
personal connection of some sort I think
being a small business owner probably
can be quite lonely sometimes if you're
not careful so having this Collective as
a sort of family family and sort of
community thing now because it's all of
us working together to sort of get the
place sort of going every day and and
keep it fresh
foreign
little town really full of independent
shops and that's really the key I I get
lots of visitors in the gallery that
have come for day trips or holidays and
the thing they really love best of all
about broadstairs is the independent
shops I mean now in Margate and Ramsgate
it's much the same as well and I I
personally sort of Supply
um greeting cards and other things to a
couple of the other Independents that
are in Margate and Ramsgate so it's kind
of nice to all support one another
foreign
we always do some mince pie and you know
mulled wine sort of uh sessions sort of
the usually the weekends on on the last
three weekends on the run out to
Christmas
um and I usually will paint the windows
or do some kind of design as well and
make a bit of a feature of that
Christmas Eve is always a funny one you
think maybe it might be quiet because
everyone's got homes to go to and but we
always get last minute Shoppers and
that's quite that can be a bit magical
actually sometimes if you get someone
coming in and and they'll buy something
really special and you know that's going
to a special home somewhere
if you go to a little independent shop
you'll get that lovely sort of special
extra special treatment that you perhaps
don't get you know in some of the bigger
retail outlets so yeah just you know
keep it all local support your
businesses because you know without that
none of these will survive and and um I
think we've had a fantastic couple of
years and we're lucky that we live by
the Sea and we have lots of visitors in
the summer but in the winter as well you
need them
um so yeah it's it supports small
business I think that's the key
foreign